So the cyber security industry of course
continues to talk about spending more
money, more layered defense, more um
defense in depth as they put it, but
actually that's because they're still
trying to protect the wrong thing. The
wrong thing is to have that information
in the public domain in the first place.
That's the mistake. So
where we set about looking at this was
that first off grids solved this
problem. Grids is the gajimaru remote
instruction dispatch serialization
architected by Craig Everett the chief
products officer of QPQ who's with me
now from Japan. And what it does is it
dis itates the two things. It says if
you are signing into a secure portal,
you don't actually give a login and
password that can be hacked. You provide
a secure authentication cryptographic
code from one to the other. A key from
public key A to public key B.